okay today I'm going to talk to you
about irradiation and contamination
these are both methods by which people
can be affected by radioactive sources
so first of all I'm going to talk to you
about irradiation
now irradiation is just when you are
exposed to a radioactive source now let
me show you an example so if we imagine
in a room let's say there was just this
particular radioactive source is just
left out on the side now here is a
person he goes into that room now
this object is emitting radiation
now that radiation is going to affect
this person here whilst they are in that
room however the important thing about
radiation sorry irradiation is it does
not make something radioactive now what
does that mean that means that this
person will only be affected by that
radioactive source when their own close
proximity to that radioactive source
let's say the second this person leaves
the room and they go elsewhere
they are absolutely fine they are no
longer going to be affected by this
radioactive source that is irradiation
now how do we prevent people being
damaged by by means of radiation because
for example in hospitals we have people
who work all day long taking x-rays so a
couple of different things can be done
three different things are going to show
you first of all at all times when the
radioactive source isn't being used it
should be stored in a lead box lead if
thick lead won't let any type of
radiation through alpha beta or gamma
secondly let's say this person is
working the hospital taking x-rays
all day long when there are when the
x-rays are being taken they can actually
go into a different room so they
actually go into a different room and by
doing so they're no longer exposed there
or they won't be exposed to the
radioactive source so the second thing
is a different room and thirdly what
they can do if you work in a hospital
you can wear this little badge which is
photographic film badge now what that
does is that actually gives you an
indication of how much radiation you've
been exposed to and therefore you could
if it's getting high you can therefore
take measures to make sure you are not
being exposed any more okay so that's
irradiation the other one we need to
look at is contamination
now this one is potentially a little a
little bit more serious because this is
when radio active atoms get onto an
object so let's just imagine we've got a
radioactive source right here but this
time this person has done over and they
have touched that radioactive source
right there so here they are apologies
for my stick man but they have touched
this radioactive source right here okay
now this can be more serious because it
by touching this without any gloves on
the radioactive source has got on to
their hands so all the time these these
radioactive atoms could decay and as
they decayed they emit radiation now
unlike with can irradiation with
contamination when this person leaves
this place they are still going to be
affected by the radioactive source
because it's physically on them
releasing radiation at all times
so they are not safe even if they are to
leave the place where this radioactive
source is because it's now on them
that's what contaminated
means in this context so what could be
done to prevent contamination so first
of all whenever handling radioactive
sources this person should obviously be
wearing gloves
they also shouldn't be picking the
radioactive source up with their hands
they should be using tongs and in
certain cases depending on the type of
the the kind of strength of the
radioactive source they could even or it
could even be appropriate for them to be
wearing a full-on protective suit by
doing this it means that even if some
radioactive materials to get on the seat
when they take off the suit it will no
longer be affecting them so that is the
difference between irradiation and
contamination thank you